for conference seriously it's been a
long hard road to this point but this is
a new era for Scotland and for Britain
The Tide is turning on the tourists and
the SMP
now anas's right to thank the first
Minister for her service and I will do
the same
to lead Scotland for almost a decade
it's a political achievement that must
be acknowledged
and one thing we need to be clear about
wherever you stand on the Constitutional
issue we must respect those beliefs as a
sincere desire to make the future better
for Scotland
the first Minister was sincere about
that and it shaped her service to this
nation and yes it shaped her political
success